hello everyone since you enjoyed game
number 15 so much here is game number 16
of the World Chess Championship match
1960 between my cattle and the Mikhail
Botvinnik here botanique has the white
pieces and again tal has to decide what
to play as you can see in the code above
the board after home thinking Koblenz
and I came to a rather bold decision to
once again entered the lion's den which
which basically means that once again at
all will go for the names of Indian
Defence I have and for the sharp night
early 94 variation because he thinks
that he definitely had some chances
there in the previous game he had the
black pieces in game game 14 and that
here he will probably have the most
chances to create something so let's see
this game I guess the tally still 2
points in the lead and still this is
like I believe the 4th or maybe the 5th
game that's drawn so very very you know
a feisty match and as the title of the
video suggests it's gonna be is gonna be
a very crazy position so let's check it
out
botanics like we said has the white
pieces and he plays d4 so Knight to f6
c4 e6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 so
the names of Indian defense we have 83
Bishop captures pawn captures like we
had in game 1494 so preventing this idea
of F 3 and E 4 due to Queen Queen coming
to h4 Queen to c2 attacking the knight
and now f5 and I thought yeah this is
the exact same recommendation at amount
of recommends in his book but he he
thinks that after f5 blacks the game is
is simply you know at least equal and
here
Botany plays Knight to h3 but the
problem about Knight to h3 is that town
will Botvinnik could play this but
botanique again spent over 15 minutes on
this move and what we knew that he would
play this move but this is something
that Botnick always does which kind of
distilled towel that botanique didn't
really prepare anything extra for this
variation you know even though they
already played it in game 14
because if he had he probably wouldn't
spend 15 minutes here so I thought
probably thought that Botvinnik had the
idea that maybe this was just the
something tall wanted to try once in
game 14 and he will not use it again for
the rest of the match but he was wrong
so Knight to h3 d6 now comes f3 kicking
the night away Knight f6 and d4 and here
d4 was kind of a novelty but not really
as tall does know of a game Bishop to g5
it's a game played between toler's and
loot akov where black after Bishop to g5
had a pretty nice game after E 5 III and
h6 Bishop to h4 and Queen to e7 last
I'll really enjoyed blacks position
after this series of moves
so both Finnick obviously knows of this
as well so after this movie for is
coming here we have F captures only 4f
captures on e4 and e5 other than e5 Tao
says that castling here is a possibility
and I mean why wouldn't you Castle you
get a nice open file for your rook the
knight can unite and come to g4 you can
create some interesting ideas here the
Queen can come into the game the problem
is tall says that here white can go if v
if you don't stop e5 by 25 yourself D
captures on e5 d captures on e5 and
Knight to g4 now Bishop to d3 attacking
the h7 pawn and here it was considered
that this was a double-edged position
here in today's modern age of engines
it's it you can simply check out this
position and the engine will tell the
Queen to h4 I simply much better for
black but in those days
King 31 Knight captures Bishop to g5 it
was considered a double-edged position
or maybe maybe not so much but it wasn't
analyzed because I had the player
playing the black pieces would not go
into this so instead after F captures on
e4 e5 now stopping a5 by white we have
nice 2 F 2 we have castles now Bishop to
e2 and c5 botany plays D captures on e5
instead of closing the position
to d5 he does have the bishop pair he
doesn't wanna close structure in the
center so D captures an e5 d captures on
e5 and now castles Knight to c6 Bishop
to g5 and here after some consideration
thoughtfully the Queen to e8 he wants to
unpin like he don't like this pin from
the bishop and g5 but it's exactly this
position that resulted in the title of
this video as here as tal tal explains
that he thought that he was doomed but
to further increase your pleasure of
watching this game I did prepare this
part from the book so here it is we can
check it out while we show you the moves
Tull says in particular after making the
last move which is Queen to e8 I
suddenly discovered that White has a
forced win by continuing Knight to b3
the C pawn is under attack as you can
see and the white threatens to spoil the
pawn structure on the Kings side of
course by playing Bishop captures on f6
and following rook captures on f6 so it
seemed to me that the continuation
Knight captures on e4 does not work in
view of rook captures on f8 Queen
captures on f8 Knight captures on e5
Knight captures on g5 and that here
Botany had Queen captures on h7 and that
this was checkmate and further on tall
says it was only one I completely
panicked and in a frenzy that I was able
to realize that in the final position it
is a Black Knight that defends the white
queen and h7 obviously this kind of mate
is rarely encountered in chess so this
is something you will not see very often
here maybe even not here very often
especially for someone you know who is
trying to win the World Chess
Championship even admit such a thing
because tile actually thought that this
was the position if there was a white
knight here then this would indeed be
checkmate but also this and you know
that's basically just wasting time or
hallucinating over the board
so after Queen to e8 bottoming of course
played nice to d1 he didn't see any of
any of these ghosts and now Queen to g6
Bishop captures on f6 rook captures on
f6 and night to e3 finally a botanics
remodeling of the knight is completed
the knight is not ready
to come to d5 and from there it will be
a very dangerous piece that can always
go to go to e7 so rook captures on f1
rook captures on f1 and now Bishop to e6
Bishop e6 is a better idea than for
example Queen to g5 attacking the e3
night because here rook to f3 is a very
powerful move for botanique then the
rook can come to g3 attack the Queen
Knight can come to f5 black will be
forced to capture the night and white
white will have a very nice position
so after rook to f1 Bishop to e6 now the
rock can also come into the game it's a
very good idea for black Queen to d3 at
trying to take advantage of the week d6
Square rook to d8 attacking the Queen
and now comes Knight to d5 and here you
can see the idea of 925 obviously if tal
plays a silly move like for example a 6
then botany can immediately win the game
with Knight to d7 check now you you can
capture of course then you get Queen
captures and the eight fold by Queen
captures on f8 which will be checkmate
but if you play King h8 it's pretty much
the same thing and now comes Queen
captures on d8 Knight captures and rook
to FH pressure blocks and rook captures
and g8 again with a nice checkmate
so after Knight to d5 tells us that he
missed rook to the 7 which appears to be
a better idea then the bishop also will
be defending the rook he played rook to
f8 and now comes knife to c7 attacking
the bishop rook captures on f1 Bishop
captures on f1 and now Queen to f7 Queen
to d6 now with a double attack on the
bishop on e6 and here we have Bishop to
c8 unfortunately Bishop captures on c4
doesn't work for tau because Bishop
captures in Queen captures and now you
get night to e6
the threat is Queen to f8 checkmate so
after King two came to have 7 again you
get Queen to f8 check King captures and
now Queen to g8 check the king a king
has to move and then you lose the Queen
and the game
so after King to b6 Bishop to c8 toggles
back has to defend
and now what eunuch plays Knight to a6
and here it becomes obvious that tal
will definitely lose a pawn as the both
Knight and Queen are threatening this
the c5 pawn if you capture then you're
double your pawns and you can capture
your knight here and something like
Queen to e7 Tull mentions this Queen to
e7 move and it appears to be a nice move
because after Queen captures Knight
captures and Knight captures on c5 you
do have you are up a pawn as white but
those are CC bonds so probably probably
a black can draw this game but he
doesn't want to risk it so after Knight
if not a sex doll decides to go for a
counter-attack he plays a Queen to f4 we
have Queen to d5 and now instead of
going to d5 you could go for something
like Knight captures on c5 but knife
chapters on c5 doesn't work in regards
of Queen to e3 check King moves and now
Queen to f2 and you can't defend both
Queen captures on f1 and if bishop moves
Queen to e1 which will result in
checkmate your only defense would be
Queen to d3 to defend the bishop but now
simply Queen captures on c5 as the
knight is undefended
so instead botanique plays Queen 35
attack stars queen and king and g8 we
have King to h8 forcing the King into
the corner and now Queen to c5 capturing
the point with the Queen now also
keeping an eye on this and this nice
diagonal so tile can't check a check
botanics King and here Bishop to e6 you
don't wanna you don't want to capture
our pawn like this
Queen to a fate would be checkmate so
first top plays Bishop to e6 now Queen
captures only 4 definitely is a threat
because Bishop can always retreat to g8
now we have Knight the c7 and here
bishop the g8 immediately Tollett
consider Knights the d4 actually here
with the idea that if C capture Sundy
for Queen to e3 check King h1 and Queen
to f2 there's really you know there's
not a lot of moves white can play but to
what can actually play h3 here and after
capture ask engage to
Queen a4 it would be a draw by
repetition so the problem would not be
for his if botany plays Knight to d5
then dental is lost the problem is the
Queen simply is has too much influence
on the c5 square design the see a square
and also the F H square so you can't
capture the night because you get
Quintus e8 which will result which will
be terrible after we captured the night
and you can't move the Queen from f4 if
you move the Queen then then Queen to f8
will be an idea if with the Queen moves
from the F file so after you play Knight
to b3 you attack the Queen again on c5
then simply Queen to b5 and now you're
again threatening to capture the knight
on v3 and also to capture the Queen here
so you will have to move the Queen and
then you simply lose a piece so although
it seems like a move that forces a draw
after this Bishop to g8 nice to d4
doesn't really accomplish anything
because Knight to d5 is a beautiful
counter by botanique so Queen to f2 we
have Queen captures on e4 and now Knight
the e8 it's a pretty it's a pretty mean
idea here
Queen to f8 would be an idea by botnik
and after tal retreats would Queen to g6
at protect the g7 square then Bishop to
d3 would be an idea trying to deflect
the Queen and then capture of course in
g7 and checkmate well it's a idea in
progress but it's definitely there so
Queen to g6 immediately Queen to f8 and
now II for if for seems like seems like
an excellent move tal says that he's not
up upon but with the CC pawns it's
almost as if he is up one so why not
push his passport also making make room
for your knight year on e5 the knight
can come from me 5 to d3 even block this
bishop so that it was very satisfied
with this move Knight to d6 now we have
Knight to e5 and here c5 making room for
the Bishop Bishop to c4 will definitely
be an idea here trying to pressure the
bishop on g8 or and force an exchange
nights here and here night the d3 was
played Queen to g5 who into g5 who was
also something talk considered but but
he quickly gave up on it so night to d3
blocking the bishop and now Knight to f5
the knight an f5 is doing pretty much
the same thing as it was doing any eight
only only much more because g7 still
pressuring g7 but from here he's also
guarding the D D three square so tell
can't really put that a passed pawn and
it's much nicer central square here nice
to e-file but also panicked here tell
again started hallucinating here because
he actually considered Queen to g5 here
and after h4 he considered Quinta in
Queen to f4 because he thought that okay
now he can't play nice to his seven
because his Queen is undefended when I
fade but he totally missed again death
Queen captures and g7 would result in
checkmate in one so tall dodged a lot of
bullets this game it's you know it's
miracle he didn't get checkmate it in in
at least a few opportunities so nice to
e5 has to go back to defend 97 attacking
the Queen and now it's gonna be a bit of
a worse endgame for for tall Queen turf
7 Queen captures Bishop captures and now
came to f2 immediately starting to
improve Bishop to c4 Bishop captures we
have Knight captures and this is more 38
instead of capturing here with the
Bishop botanique missed missed a slight
improvement in his position with c6 and
now this knight on e5 is overloaded
guarding the bishop here and also
guarding the c6 square but okay you know
it's moved 38 you have to reach time
control can't can't see everything so
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
he pushes c6 be characters on c6 Knight
captures on c6 and a5 this is this is
move 40 and now in in this position the
game was adjourned but it's pretty
obvious which move which move between
equal play tomorrow
of course the move is a 4 as the pond
and a3 is under attack
and here tell my uncle once again
analyzed this game long into the night
so after a four you can play something
like King g8 then comes King III King f7
King before e3 now the point is
protected by the night King he has to go
to f3 but now after King comes to e6 as
you do have to improve the position of
the black King as well then you can go
King to before and you can't push the
night because Knight d4 for example
check the King and also picks up D to
pawn so after King D 6 now Knight d4
protecting and after a couple of moves
checks this Botvinnik will grab b3
pontiff will grab the e4 pawn so now
it's a pretty pretty simple position and
you know they could still play on this
position but Indian they agree to a draw
before before the game was even
continued so yeah that's games game
number 16 again a very very very feisty
battle between the two of them I do hope
you enjoyed it and again it's very
interesting
tall tall imagining ghosts and
hallucinating twice at least twice that
he admits in the book in this game so
yeah I would like to thank a Miroslav
here for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I will make both of them
videos from the table tunics series if
you want you can check all of the other
previous 15 games the link will be in
the description below also if you
haven't I do suggest you check out my
coverage of the 1959 candidates
tournament it's a tournament all had to
win to gain this opportunity to even
challenge both win it for the title it's
a very enjoyable tournament so I do I do
recommend it and yeah that's it see you
soon with game number 17 thank you all
for watching and yeah have it have a
great rest of the evening